cloud, data, apps, all of that. You
know, is it a humanborn threat? We
created the data. Now, you can sit here
and say we created the system. Systems
are creating the data. We can as you
start getting into AI,
AI, machine learning, you know, I I'm
going just use the general term right
now of of AI for generative AI. You've
got AI generated data. Well, it's still
humans created the AI, the AI creates
the data. It's all humans. It's all
people. Humans are humans are our
greatest sensors because we still have
intuition. But humans are also the
greatest threat that we have out there.
Whether it's insider threat, whether
it's a activist, whether it's a nation
state actor, it's still a person on both
sides of the of the equation. We don't
have machines attacking machines yet. We
have humans attacking humans. And
whether they're going after my data,
whether they're just trying to knock me
offline with a distributed denial of
service, it's still humans attacking
humans.
[Music]
Benjamin Coral, welcome to the human
zero day. I'm so excited for this
conversation. I've been so looking
forward to it. Thank you so much for
being here.
>> Oh, absolutely. Excited.
very much appreciating your time,
Benjamin. Um, listen, you've had a lot
of experience in the security space. And
I'm I'm going to jump right in. Um, you
know what? Before I jump right into
human security, tell me why you got into
security.
So, saying I have a lot of experience. I
think that's a subtle way of calling me
old. So, I appreciate I didn't hear
that. That's you.
Now uh I really got into security
so because I wanted to help people. I
wanted to protect people and there are
bad people in the world. You know it bad
people do bad things and in order to
stop bad people from doing bad things
you have to have good people who are
willing to stop the bad people from
doing bad things. That is what really
drew me to security is how do I stop
this badness from happening? I don't
have to go after bad people. That's law
enforcement. But I need to protect
organizations. That's what really drew
me to security is that defender or that
protector perspective.
Incredible. Okay. So, there's many
different threats to organizations. Are
there particular types of threats that
particularly drew you closer to this
world?
The in short when I started in security
it was IP tables and it was antivirus on
workstations. So when I came it was
really the the hackists or the
opportunistic hackers that were out
there and yes all called hackers at the
time we can say cyber criminals now but
at the time it was more malware of
stopping machines having to rebuild
machines. It was a pain in the tokus. So
that how do we protect how do we make
sure and how do we keep people out and
you know access control lists that that
was pretty sufficient back in the day
but that's not sufficient today. But
that those are some of the threats that
were there and then it became that cat
mouse of as the attacks get more
sophisticated because the attackers
behind them more more sophisticated
and really that mindset of it's
something different every day. That that
that was the other thing of how do I
make sure that my program is sufficient.
I don't have to stop every attacker from
every type of attack from getting in. I
have to make my organization
just a little bit more difficult to get
into that this opportunistic attacker is
going to try to Yeah, this is a pain.
I'm going move on to someone else.
>> It's easier.
>> It's okay. You know, if you and I are
get if you and I are stuck in a forest
together and I spot a bear that's
running at us, I don't have to run
faster than the bear. I need to run
faster than you. And well, you you you
need to move faster than me because you
know I like you and all everything. I
you're younger. You're half my age. I'm
not going to outrun you. I'm going to
trip you and I'm going to keep running.
>> I love it. So, so Benjamin, many things
to protect against lots of cat and mouse
games in cyber from cloud to data to
applications to um databases to to the
code vulnerabilities,
operating systems, humans.
What's happening with humans?
Well, everything that you just, you
know, mentioned is it's all humans. So
cloud, data, apps, all of that. You
know, is it a humanborn threat? We
created the data. You can sit here and
say we created the system. Systems are
created in the data. We can as you start
getting into AI, AI, machine learning,
you know, I I'm going just use the
general term right now of of AI for
generative AI. You've got AI generated
data. Well, it's still humans created
the AI. The AI creates the data. It's
all humans. It's all people. Humans are
humans are our greatest sensors because
we still have intuition. But humans are
also the greatest threat that we have
out there. Whether it's insider threat,
whether it's a activist, whether it's a
nation state actor, it's still a person
on both sides of the of the equation. We
don't have machines attacking machines
yet. We have humans attacking humans.
Whether they're going after my data,
whether they're just trying to knock me
offline with a distributed denial of
service, it's still humans attacking
humans. And what are the most common
attacks that you've seen, let's say, in
the last two to three years in the
context of humans attacking humans? I I
probably most of it is financially
motivated, but what what are practically
the types of attacks that you're seeing?
So it's all that financially motivated
is generally what I'm going to see. But
what are they trying to do? And you
prevalence. I'm still shocked at the
prevalence of ransomware. And we
shouldn't be because you have ransomware
as a service now. You you have for you
know half a decade as well of these
these it's a subscription model. So it's
it's become commoditized. It's easier to
do now. So that's but ransomware is just
still malware. It's just one more
version of malware or that malicious
software things like that. This
financially motivated and one of the
things on that is business email
compromise of you know I'm sure you've
heard the adage of criminals don't have
to
to compromise you. They don't have to
hack you. Criminals are no longer
hacking into your organization. They're
logging in to your organization. So, all
I've got to do is get your credentials
and if are you using the same
credentials for all of your different
accounts or are using a password manager
with unique for every account that's out
there, but if if they get access to, you
know, it was years ago, but if they get
access to LinkedIn and they get the
credentials there, what other accounts
can they log into as well? Are you
resharing those passwords? So, those
business email are compromised. they're
able to get into Acme,
but Acme third party. Now, Acme is a
supplier to Amazon, to Cisco, to to
Microsoft, to these to Apple in these
larger enterprises, these larger
organizations. Now, they can go in and
they can say, "Oh, you you're a customer
here." they can get in, use these same
emails, use the templates, use all of
those things and they can craft a very
realistic looking and they now own this.
So whether they're spoofing a domain,
whether the or whether they're logging
into the real domain here and sending it
saying please change the the bank
account and it's on the real right
letter hag.
everything looks right or they have a a
you know they've comp compromised they
can now create a rule inside this email
so it's coming from the right email but
any responses can be forwarded somewhere
or it can be moved out of the inbox to
where the real recipient or the real
sender there the box that's been
compromised doesn't even know that
you're doing it and that you have access
to their account really bad things very
common now And I have a question, maybe
a simple one, but it's it's still an
important one nevertheless. We've been
building really phenomenal services to
help us combat viruses and malware and
intrusions on so many different aspects
which are seem quite successful in
detecting breaches, right? The world of
detection and response, the it's a big
big space. Why isn't this the the sort
of the big solution to what you're
alluding to are as business email
compromise social engineering attacks
that you know if you look at them you
can pretty much point to them and say ah
we should be able to detect this.
>> Mhm.
And and that's the thing is there's no
silver bullet here and there's no easy
button that you can push and it also
comes down to real adoption. Technology
exists and if you implement technologies
that are there with the defense you
meaning you have multiple tools. If one
tool misses the other catches if one
tool misses the is the other one there.
How well have you implemented? Are you
properly monitoring? Are you reducing
the, you know, not just the attack
surface, but the blast radius? I did
mess up. My machine got compromised.
Am I connected to a network of other
machines? Now, I'm sitting here on my
home machine. If you compromise my home
machine, can you get to my kids
machines? Can you get to any of my smart
devices on the network? Well, I have
multiple networks in my house. You're
not going to be able to jump from device
to device because it's a segmented
network. What are we doing? How do we
reduce that radius that blast radius of
if we can't prevent it? Can we at least
minimize and reduce the impact? Now, of
course, I want to to prevent it and
there are other technologies talking
about the business email compromise.
Your credentials are out there. If it do
we have the unique ones for every
account? Well, how many login do you
have? Well, if I go in my password
manager, I have just shy of 300 accounts
that it manages. So, I could have unique
passwords and this manager will tell me
if I have reused passwords. So, it'll
give the passwords for me, but
conveniently it integrates to my
websites, whether on my mobile device or
on my personal device. So you've got
multiffactor.
So all of my financial websites, my my
retirement account, my where my direct
deposit goes as well. All of those
require multiffactor.
And you've got other things of
multiffactor is your username, your
password, a biometric, something you
are, someone you are, someone you know,
something that you have, 502 with
different things like UB keys is one
more way of going about it of how do we
reduce, but how do I know you are who
you say you are? And all of this starts
culminating into that defense and depth.
But one of the things that I'm really
really passionate about is stopping stop
using yester year's technology
and I really with the human factor
everything that it's there. How do we
use technology wisely and I'm an
advocate of adopting zero trust models
and not just buzzwords.
We could throw a lot of acronyms out,
but really, how do I stop connecting
people to networks? How do I connect
resources?
Give me an identity to a resource. I'm
only going to connect you once you've
authenticated. Tell me who you are. Does
the connection make sense? Where are you
connecting to? How do I connect you only
to a resource?
>> And how do I tear that access down when
that session's done? Now you want to
reconnect, reauthenticate, but make it
easy on the end user as well. Yeah.
>> Is it the same person coming from the
same
make it easy but also make it secure.
Now help me place
the problem of
human security related issues in the
larger in the larger context of
different risks in terms of in the
context of cyber security and and I'm
going back to you know in the beginning
you said you know everything is human
you know ultimately everything is
generated by human everything is
operated by human but but there are
different different ways in which you as
a CESO
may think about protecting organizations
from creating you know firewalls to
looking at your cloud uh to to you know
cloud security posture management to DLP
systems right you're spending money on a
bunch of these different things where in
terms of the you know how big of a pain
point where does the human
susceptibility to social engineering
fall in line with these other pain
points that you're actively resolving in
the day-to-day.
>> Yeah. And I'd like to say, you know,
we're getting better. And humans,
humans are prayed upon and they pray
upon us using our emotions. Humans, you
know, humans taking advantage of other
humans and a lot of the social
engineering that that comes along. And I
can give you examples of, you know, how
I took advantage of when I was doing pin
testing and red teaming and things like
that, but a lot of it comes down to, you
know, humans being duped because of the
motions. We can talk about deep fakes
and things like that are that are now
becoming more and more prevalent. We can
talk about the types of LLMs that are
out there that are being used by cyber
criminals to create more realistic
looking
more realistic looking so it's not chat
GBT cuz if you go in there and use chat
GPT but it's other GPTs you know rogue
GPT for instance is something that
within four or five prompts of things
that you enter the things you're typing
in that are the questions you're asking
or prompts to the GPT within four or
five prompts, you can write a whole
campaign to take advantage to to repaint
a website to make it look like a
password reset for almost any account.
And then you send that link and now your
users are being duped into it saying
your password has has expired. Enter
your old enter your credentials, your
username, your password, and your new
password that you want to. And then all
of a sudden, they enter that information
and it's a prompt that comes up. We were
not uh we were not able to process this.
please try again later. But it takes
your username and your password and
sends it to the attacker who then will
try to log on using your credentials.
Yeah, all of those things become so much
easier with some of these advances in
and these GPTs that are out there. So,
but also things that I did as a red
teamer is people want to help and you
sit there and say, "Can you help me out
with this?" And how do you get into a
building that has guards there? Well,
you know, you don't go through the front
door. You go to the back door and you or
you go out to smoker's corner and you
walk in with the people that are out
there smoking. They all start walking in
together. The the smoke break is over.
People walk in. All right. You think
you're going to be questioned, walk up
with a couple boxes of donuts. Your
hands are full. They're going to hold
the door for you and let you walk in.
It's little thing. People want to help.
And if no one's holding the door for
you, you ask. You put them on the spot.
Hey, my badge is in my back pocket. Can
you either reach in my back pocket? Make
it things awkward. Can you reach in my
back pocket or could you simply grab the
door for me? You put them on the spot.
Nobody wants to be confrontational.
Nobody wants to say no. And no one wants
to awkwardly reach into your back
pocket. That's going to be empty. Oh, I
must have left it in my car. Little
things like that. People want to be
helpful, but they also don't want to
confront. So, put them on the spa. Ask
them ask them to open the door if they
don't volunteer to do it. So, that's
another way uh of duping it. The other
thing can can also come in of you are
you know why would they hold a door for
for people of they don't see the value
in the controls. So, please you know
don't allow people to tailgate behind
you. But we're humans. Oh, that looks
like Bob from accounting. I recognize
Bob. I'm gonna hold the door for Bob.
I'm not gonna let the door slam in his
face. So, there's also that factor of
not understanding that we still need,
you know, the security team. I want to
see Bob's badge. I want to know, you
know, I need to know how many people are
actually working in this building at any
given time. If there's a fire, if
there's anything, who do we need to, you
know, can we give the fire marshall a
list of employees we know are in the
building?
little things of from that perspective
of knowing who was there. It's not
because I'm trying to catch badges or
count badges and know who was there and
were you six minutes late. I don't care
about any of that. But from a human
accountability perspective,
so yeah, but there's also the humans
will go around our security controls
that they don't understand if it's a
convenience factor.
>> And what do I mean by this? Well, those
badges, USB sticks, you know, going
around. I I'm tired, you know, I need
this file. Yeah, I need to work on this
file from home. I don't have a laptop. I
mean, everybody has laptops now, but I
have a desktop in the office. You know,
I'm going to copy this and then I'm
going to work on this from home. Uh,
well, now this USB stick I copied on to
it's my own USB stick. Did I infect
malware now? inject malware because that
USB stick or is it a data breach because
I'm copying sensitive information onto
it to work from home. Did my DLP catch
it? Yep. Things like that. Oh, you can't
use USB sticks. I copied to my own
Dropbox.
Well, now I have copy of sensitive
information and I the administrator can
no longer see it or my controls are
inadequate. it different reasons. I
don't think any of that was malicious.
There's malicious insiders from
disgruntled people as well. Or you can
sit there and talk about corporate
espionage of here's $10,000. Plug this
USB stick in and you give that to the
cleaning crew as they're going through.
There's there's all that's that's
malicious. That's intentional.
>> Absolutely. So in going back to the
question of how you prioriti how you are
prioritizing your time thinking through
these types of risks and you were
talking a lot about the physical risks
but I imagine that every each of these
physical risks can be also asserted to a
digital one right that just simply over
email phone SMS can be the same same
notion as can you hold the door for me
you know right um how how do you think
through how much time and energy you're
spending your as a CISO or or as your
others are spending at CESOS protecting
from that versus protecting from other
things. Well, that's the thing is
everybody has this mobile device they
carry with them everywhere and
how do I get you know how do I protect
and is it a corporate device is it a
personal device if it's a personal
device what type of data can it have on
it you know do you put an MDM mobile
device management solution on there but
all of those things is
I believe I have adequate controls on
devices that I manage
Now, if I'm attacking you and I'm trying
to get into your organization,
I know that I'm unlikely to get it
through your corporate apps. So, I'm
going to send you a, you know, I'm now
going to Signal. I'm going to WhatsApp.
I'm going to Telegram. I'm going outside
the enterprise application and I'm now
going to hit you up through that. I got
your phone number somehow and now I'm
sending you something through a
non-corporate and I'm going to pretend
to be an executive at your company and
I'm going to say, "Hey, you work in
finance." I'm going to say, "Hey, hey,
Michael, I've lost Yep. This is Jim. I'm
the CFO. I'm the controller. I've lost
my corporate access. I'm about to jump
on a plane.
I need you to do this in the next two
hours. I need it done before I land or
we're doing a merger with this company.
It's all hush hush. I've lost my
corporate device. I need you to process
this for me. Please keep it off the
company because we This is still hush
hush. It's still in the project phase.
We can't have it going through. You know
me. This is my face. This is where the
deep fakes with the voices come in of
I'm sending you an authorization via
audio file. As soon as I as soon as I
hit send here, listen, you're going to
recognize my voice. This is your
authorization to process it. Little
things. This is in a digital world. You
know that person. That's your boss's
boss. And you get it in. Yeah, it sounds
like them. Well, those are very easy to
create now. very cheap to create as
well. If it's not free, it's, you know,
pennies or dollars in order to create
something like this. And but how much,
you know, validity or validation do we
put into that of, yeah, that sounds like
the CEO, that sounds like the chief
operating or chief financial officer.
Therefore, I'm now going to process
this.
>> So, what do we do about that?
>> Train train people. let them know yeah
better better controls better tools but
I do believe this is at defense and
depth if my technology fails does the
human layer know that these things exist
does it pass the sniff test have
processes in place before somebody can
pay a you know purchase order purchase
release all of these things when it goes
above 5,000 10,000 you know 50,000 or
you know what whatever that is do you
have things in place your processes in
place. Does it need a second set of
eyes? Does it now need a finance
director to approve? Put put controls
processes in place and train your people
to let them know that these sorts of
threats exist and to be be aware of them
and when you receive them, how you
validate. Is it from a known number? Can
you now go on a an internal Slack? And
you know that last one of that CFO hit
you up. Can you at least say Mr. or Mrs.
CFO?
I received something through Telegram.
Can you confirm that this is you?
You're not asking any details. You're
not giving out project names. You're
not. But you are saying, is this truly
you? Or you can get on with a their
their executives. So, hit up their
executive assistant and say, "I just
received something from or purporting to
be from. Is this saying they're about to
jump on a plane? Can you confirm?" No,
I'm in the meeting with them right now.
I can confirm they did not send.
>> How do you reliably
create a training system that takes into
account the externality
of the way that these attacks are coming
in? Because yes, we've had pre-recorded
videos before. We've even had email
fishing campaigns internally, but like
you said, these attacks are no longer
just limited in scope to the enterprise
systems. They're out in the coming from
the external world.
>> Yes.
and how do I train my people and make it
relevant to them and sharing these
examples of things that have happened to
our organization in the past.
>> This happened 6 months ago. This
happened 6 weeks ago or what are some of
the painful things that have happened in
your organization? Even if it was from 2
years ago, did it hurt bad enough? And
in the US now with the new SEC
regulations that are there of material
breaches and materiality and stuff.
Remember we had to do an 8K on an
incident in 2023. I mean it wasn't
reportable but still you can make
mention of we are still rolling things
out. This is the way that they were able
to take advantage of. Therefore
those are the types of things that are
real and relevant. It's not happened to
some other company somewhere in the
world. This impacted us. It makes it
more real. That's some of the things.
But also you I used to get hit up of oh
we have our annual security training
coming again. We're going to have to
watch these three five minute videos.
And people would you know be groaning
it. People would see me walking by and
they would tell me, "Hey, you know, I'm
helping through the videos." And others
would be like, "Yeah, just hit play on
the video, walk away, come back, you
know, go get a cup of coffee, come back,
it'll be done because you can't skip
it." And then just answer the two, three
questions. You don't have to really
watch it. It's all common sense. So, how
do you make it engaging? How do you make
it real for them? Because at the end of
the day, we're we're investing the time
to buy those solutions. We're investing
the time to have people take it. We
don't want them skirting around a system
because it's not engaging. So, what
would be engaging? Ask them. Ask them
what's going to be more engaging and is
it going to be things that are real or
relevant to them? And when does it
become relevant to them? And one of the
things I realized when I was chatting to
different board of directors, different
board members, is I had a board member
coming to me saying, "I now have a
teenage granddaughter and I remember
that you were talking to me about social
social media and I kind of zoned out
because I don't use social media, but
now my 14-year-old granddaughter is
asking to get social media. Do you have
training that I can take so I can have a
conversation with her or do you have
training for her? And it became real for
her at that point.
How do we make it real?
And what have you found to be more
effective practically?
There's I know there is a few schools of
thought when it comes to training.
There's let me share with you a concept
like fishing. Let me share with you a
case study of something that happened to
us and then there's let me let me show
you how it actually looks like and
depending on how you how you react then
I will know where you're at and how to
train you better but you will have
experience that which of these is most
effective and which of these do you
think we can actually use tangibly in
the context of these new and emerging
threats?
The short answer is yes. All of them.
It's situational case by case basis. Do
we do the training and then you know not
once a year but how do we do it
continuously giving it to the different
teams? I'm giving the business email
compromise more to my finance team. I'm
going to give something different to my
DevOps team. I'm going to give something
different. You know account takeovers
going to my DevOps team. Things like
that. I'm not giving everybody the same
training. They may get the same general
overall introduction to to something,
but I'm probably going to give the
business email compromised things to
finance or you know those types of
organizations. My executives whailing,
spear fishing, they're going to get a
little bit extra. Same thing for my
board members. They're going to get
different. So, I'm not hitting everybody
with the same thing over and over. Do I
have frequent offenders? People who fail
fishing tests? I want to praise people
who pass it and then I want to engage
those who continually fail. And we used
to put up the seven signs of of seven
indicators, poor language written that
poorly that everybody should be able to
discern that this is fishing. And I'm
like, you're reading this from an
American perspective.
And what I mean by that is you're
reading it as an American in broken
English because most of the fishing
messages were coming in written in
broken English. And I'm like, you see
that? But somebody with English as a
second or third language, it is written
by somebody with English as a second
language and somebody else with English
as a second language doesn't pick up on
those nuances.
Therefore, how do we train them? How do
we, you know, I don't even want that
message making it to their inbox. So, is
it a technology issue before it's a
human issue? So, let's improve our
controls that are here yet. Let's also
train our people relevant of what might
be coming down and using your
newsletters, using your internal ways,
using your different ways of
communicating, but that frequent
offender now of I see for the last three
times you had issues or you clicked or
you even entered information into this
portal and then you're having a
conversation with them. Not to not to
you're violating my acceptable use. Do
it one more time, you're going to get
fired. No, I want to train them because
if I train them to be a better sensor,
they detect more things and they're
going to talk to others. Did security
come and smack them? That whole carrot
versus stick. I want to train them to be
a much better sensor and now to be an
advocate for me.
>> Benjamin, this was such an interesting
and enlightening conversation. Thank you
so much for for spending this time with
me and for sharing with me your
perspective and excitement about this
space. It really came through. So I
really want to thank you for being here.
This was great.
>> Thank you so much for the opportunity.
Thank you very very